hi guys I'm first of all congratulations
on an absolutely beautiful piece of
cinema my questions to Benedict's
Benedict as someone who's made such an
extraordinary success of playing a
socially abrasive heroic genius on our
small screens in recent years I'm
curious when you're approaching this
role did you feel a certain pressure to
inject Allen with nuances and and
personality traits that distinguished
him from Sherlock and given the lack of
source material available where did you
look for for that wonderful inspiration
well I mean I'm limited by who I am and
what I looked like but at the same time
that utterly different people so yes of
course and I think I did you know he
doesn't swish around in a coat with
curly hair demonstrating how brilliant
he is he's a very quiet stoic determined
different and indefinite the hero and I
think someone who yeah he's he's smarter
but I think the way that he has to
operate as an outsider and as someone
who is at all different is something
that was very much out of the conditions
of his life
and he you know as far as another
similarity that he's socially awkward
what you see is a whole evolution in him
which is humanizing and that happens I
suppose in some aspects of what we do
with our version of Sherlock but no I
didn't read the scripts and go oh this
is Sherlock in tweeze fiddling around
with valves and wires you know I like
the width of it I liked how
uncompromising he was and I suppose that
is that is a strong trait I think but
that's a strong trait in strong
characters and they always have a
traction practice of of every variety so
I yeah you find it has played stupid
people as well I want to point you on
that I mean I've anyone's got some more
stupid roles out there for me great
bring him on but um it's um you know
it's a great honor to be asked to play
somebody like uninsurance oh the last
thing I'm going to do is go well yeah
but you know it's a bit like Sherlock
isn't it because it's then it's not it's
really not and you can't begin to fathom
you know what an individual is if you
start just categorizing them as having
similarities to other characters you
played and I do try to shake it up but I
do see why people think that too clever
people might have similarities
do you find those comparisons
frustrating or understandable at no I
don't know I understand that I mean yeah
the frustrating but I do understand them
of course I do
of course I do I to watch stuff
you